une campagne présidentielle bouleversé
par l'invasion russe en ukraine à peine
arrivé à l'île de la réunion jean luc
mélenchon condamne vladimir poutine
quelles que soient les sympathies les
explications et puis ce qu'on veut il
n'est pas acceptable qu'une armée
franchissent une quelconque des
frontières de l'europe à gauche les
autres candidats réclament des actes
pour mettre fin au conflit tout doit
être mis en oeuvre pour désarmer les
armées pour faire en sorte que ça
n'aille pas plus loin notre fermeté et
notre solidarité doivent immédiatement
se traduire par des sanctions d'une
ampleur exceptionnelle contre poutine et
ses complices à droite valérie pécresse
souhaite une réponse européenne
cette attaque d'être l'occasion d'un
électrochoc pour l'europe
le temps de la naïveté est finie
désormais la plus grande lucidité
s'impose marine le pen qui a déjà été
reçu au kremlin demande de son côté la
fin des opérations militaires
aucune raison ne peut justifier le
lancement d'une opération militaire
contre l'ukraine par la russie qui rompt
l'équilibré de la paix en europe eric
zemmour son rival d'extrême droite lui
emboîte le pas l'urgence désormais est
de faire taire les armes j'appelle
solennellement le président macron à se
rendre à moscou et à kiev pour proposer
la médiation de la france afin d'obtenir
un cessez-le-feu immédiat sous la vème
république il n'y avait jamais eu de
conflit déclenché au cours d'une
campagne présidentielle c'est évident
qu'avec un conflit majeur en europe la
campagne présidentielle va pas pouvoir
se dérouler de la même manière à la fois
parce que le président est très impliqué
dans ce conflit et en même temps parce
que ma les autres candidats vont devoir
d'une certaine manière attendre un peu
car avec cette guerre les candidats vont
devoir s'adapter une situation inédite à
46 jours du premier tour